we're now gonna go to um a beautiful
theme we're gonna change scale as you
have seen we're changing scale we're
going from Urban territories to homes to
now also objects and we're going to talk
about regenerative design now there's
many ways to be sustainable there's many
ways to be responsible there's many ways
to be good citizens and you know amongst
them there's also this idea of
regenerative and it also intersects
systems and to talk about it today we
have two wonderful human beings the
first being Sarah mineco ichioca who's a
strategist and urbanist a curator a
writer and a long time partner in crime
of mine because we've been on many
panels together and committees and she's
always been a great interlocutor and
she's been working on this particular
subject for a while and also published a
beautiful book called flourish and the
second person is not say Audrey chiesa
who unfortunately could not make it here
she was already going to the airport and
then a family emergency prevented her to
leave Oslo so she's gonna join us from
uh from Oslo on zoom and she is uh she's
what her official way of saying is that
she's a designer and an equitable
development of consumer biotechnology
expert but in truth to to just tell you
our story natai and I met several years
ago because I've been studying biodesign
and she's been making biodesign and
actually being a Pioneer in that what is
interesting is that biodesign can remain
speculative and almost science fictiony
but in her case it's really about the
systems she tries to translate the
values and transform the sister systems
across education design so once again a
regenerative model so I would like to
start by calling on stage my good friend
Sarah ichioka
[Applause]
thanks so much Paola
um good evening everyone it's a huge
privilege to be here today at this
beautiful Symposium alongside so many
colleagues I respect and admire and just
as a side note three years ago my team
at desire Alliance were deeply honored
to be part of a larger team appointed by
Mark at DSG to help them reimagine a
future facing Singapore design week and
it's absolutely thrilling to see so many
of the co-created plans now coming to
fruition here with all of you
so my remarks today will seek to
supplement more technically focused
solutions to the design and development
of our built environment by taking a
culture-based approach
and as we're briefed by Paula to speak
about regenerative design today I'd like
to turn our attention to the importance
of traditional forms of knowledge around
the world in framing future debates
about how we humans can integrate the
way we live with the rest of the web of
life
in recent days over one third of our
neighbor Pakistan has been underwater
with half a million households displaced
or damaged
and at least twice the capacity of this
concert hall
having lost their lives
the Deluge brought on by heavier than
usual Monsoon rains and melting glaciers
is simply the latest
of many clear signs
to which we become we risk becoming numb
or distracted
that our extractivists industrialized
Society is simply on the path to break
down
for decades now for the most of the
lifetimes
of us in the room today we have been
looking for quote sustainable ways to
interrupt our tumble down this path
in the built environment sector where
most much of my own work is focused many
have come up with ingenious Technical
Solutions some of which we've already
heard about today and Singapore itself
has long enjoyed an illustrious
reputation for seemingly marrying Urban
Development environmental Consciousness
to create the futuristic Metropolis
nestled within Lush Greenery that we
inhabit today
and understandably such achievements in
wealthy parts of the world have tended
to reinforce the belief that it's
possible to design our way out of the
our compound crises while allowing
business to continue pretty much as
usual but more and more of us are waking
up to the reality that this is not
enough
in the three decades since
sustainability first entered the
mainstream with the brentland report
more than half of the world's total
historic greenhouse gas emissions have
been released
absolutely clear we must evolve beyond
the sustainability that perpetuates
business as usual towards framings that
open up other possibilities
it was with this aim that my dear friend
and collaborator the london-based
architect Michael Paulin and I decided
to write the new book that Paula has
kindly mentioned and this book reflects
our shared conviction that significant
shifts need to happen at the level of
our Collective mindsets
to enable us as designers or clients or
users of design to effectively build a
world that seeks not only to be less bad
but to make a net positive impact
this Vision Builds on the work of
fingers and practitioners Myriad
including Bill Reed of the Regenesis
group who's been a long time proponent
of regenerative design and development
it's also inspired by the amazing
systems thinker danella Meadows who
identified a dozen possible ways
of places that we could intervene to
affect change within a given system
she identified the two most effective at
the level of the mindset or Paradigm out
of which the system
arises and the power to transcend
paradigms when we talk about
transcending paradigms we mean creating
a different more persuasive story than
the ones that currently shape our
Collective World Views
one persistent degenerative story is
that of human exceptionalism
in this story our industrialized
dualistic view of our relationship with
the rest of the living world has made us
Earth exploiters rather than Earth
Keepers and I'm using the words here of
Professor James agude who's director of
the African Observatory for
environmental humanities
countless traditional forms of knowledge
and practices around the world are
underpinned by ideas of interdependence
bio-inclusivity and collaboration
agude whose own research draws from
various indigenous forms of ecological
conservation
is written extensively for example about
the concept of Ubuntu which translates
from nagunibantu to mean I am because we
are
it's a philosophy that rests on the
principle of co-agency and that places
emphasis on the dialogical relationship
between humans and non-humans collapsing
the dichotomy we've created between
culture and nature
what does it mean to design in a way our
way into a new or rediscovered
regenerative story which aims to replace
these deeply ingrained Notions of human
dominion over nature with the
understanding that we are in fact
participants in a diverse and
interconnected world
to make the commensurate adjustment to
our practices we must find a way to
answer the question posed by the
philosopher Freya Matthews what does
nature want us to want
but first we must Define which
particular manifestation of nature we're
addressing because the regenerative
approach to design and development will
promote a deep connection with place as
partner
this requires us as designers to
reacquire the skills to be constantly in
dialogue with that which clo Which is
closest to us
as biologist Robin while Kimmer Appley
puts it to be native to a place we must
learn to speak its language
an essential aspect of regenerative
design is that it Embraces the need to
repair past harms to the biosphere and
learn from nature however there can be a
risk here of perpetuating the old
duelist view of conservation that sees
nature as separate from us out there in
need of our protection
truly degenerative regenerative design
will operate from the understanding that
we also need to repair human culture and
understand ourselves as an integral part
of nature so to close circling back to
while kimmer's point about the
importance of spatial fluency this
implies that each Place may have its own
languages or dialects
there's a powerful complementary concept
that I'd like to turn our attention to
of the ethnosphere which was coined by
the Anthropologist Wade Davis the
ethnosphere refers to the sum total of
all thoughts dreams ideas beliefs
intuitions and Inspirations brought into
being by the human imagination since the
dawn of consciousness
in Davis's words it's a symbol of all
we've accomplished and all we can
accomplish
to regenerate the biosphere we need to
call upon the resource of human
experience in all its diversity we need
to respect protect and regenerate the
ethnosphere
in this respect regenerative design can
never be a solely technical solution it
has to be rooted in the specificities of
its socio-cultural context looking at
this diverse region of Southeast Asia we
can find many examples of built
environment practices that are fluent in
natural cultural dialects
possible there are countless possible
examples but in the Philippines we can
find still find naturally cooling
traditional houses that are not only
Built from local materials and adopted
to these climates but whose building
process is culturally grounded in
parentheses of mutual Aid what strength
and wisdom do we have just do we stand
again by humbly learning from such
practices that have and continue to
exist outside of industrialized Society
we can also look to contemporary
examples from the region including the
ARC building of the Green School in Bali
by ibuku and Atelier one which combines
deep local knowledge of craftsmanship
with Cutting Edge engineering techniques
to grasp these learning points we must
adopt a generous mindset that not only
welcomes but actively seeks out
communities and practitioners who have
shown us that we are capable of living
within other paradigms under diverse
contexts
conserving and cultivating an
ethnosphere in which a myriad of World
Views and ways of being exist can help
us imagine how to retrofit our
degenerative dualistic modern cities for
regenerative practices that care for the
web of life that sustains us and I
promise Paul is last slide specifically
for this audience where could embracing
an even wider plurality of cultures
World Views and stories take Singapore a
nation that has long been a hub of
exchange and has valued multiculturalism
from its very birth
how can Singapore model the regenerative
retrofit of its inherited spaces which
may be formally aspirational but
conceived in service to economic systems
that no longer or arguably never serve
the best interests of the majority of
Life on this planet
as people who've been entrusted to shape
our built environment we have tremendous
potential agency to bring these
imaginations to life Singapore is a
world-class example of strategic Urban
Design is in the potentially crucial
position to challenge and imbue The
Wider culture of design and development
with truly regenerative mindsets and
methods thank you for indulge Amy thank
you
thank you sir so happy you showed you
chanting I was about showing it too and
now we're gonna have natsai Audrey
chiesa and there she is hi natsai
perfect I wish you could see the
audience we're gonna send you pictures
it's a big theater and they are all
excited and not full Full House so off
you go I'm just not making you feel
Under Pressure here
thank you for the warm welcome Pala and
although I can't be there in person I'm
really thrilled to still be able to
share our perspectives on designing
transformational change with you all
today
um so Faber Futures we are a design
agency that is at the Nexus of
biotechnology and Society we work across
Industries institutions and Brands to
develop ecologically driven models for
holistic innovation
from design strategy to spatial practice
our studio
and core team operates from these
principles
we work in defense of the world to come
we design for systemic change we carry
an inquisitive attitude to novel
Solutions and deliver Mutual benefit
through collaborative effort
so today I'd like to share two projects
that embody those principles beginning
with project CD column
beauty color means sky blue in Latin
this microorganism script mycilia column
is a soil dwelling microbe we've all
encountered it in the wild it releases a
compound called yosemin or to us the
smell of rain
it also gives beetroot its flavor and
decomposes organic matter in the soil in
the lab this while studied organism
produces antibiotics for the
pharmaceutical industry
in 2011 as a recent graduate of material
Futures at Central St Martin's in London
I began a residency at the ward Lab at
University College London's Department
of biochemical engineering discovering
that culturing scriptomycity color
directly onto textiles at an ambient
temperature its natural sky blue pigment
offered a toxin-free and highly water
efficient alternative to our current
harmful practices of dyeing and printing
Fabrics
we explored what streptomyces silicolor
could do in the context of fashion
design developing replicable protocols
and tools to dye protein-based textiles
for specific aesthetic outcomes
where streptomycilia color produces its
pigment naturally synthetic biology is a
technology that will allow us to
customize the organism
where an expanded color palette perhaps
designing into the DNA of the organism
shorter lead times for the fermentation
of the desired pigment molecule at even
higher yields larger scale and lower
cost
though these are essential metrics in
our present economic system we believe
that the real transformational
possibility of the emerging bioeconomy
lies in reshaping the value drivers of
the Technologies its services
Technologies like synthetic biology are
beginning to allow us to swap out animal
and petroleum-based ingredients and
materials in everyday products for
Alternatives that are fermented by
bacteria fungi and yeast
but ignoring our underlying system
of resource extraction consumption and
waste risks placing strategic
limitations on this so-called
biomanufacturing Revolution
we already know how to ferment wine and
beer at scale but realizing the promises
of synthetic biology also requires us to
scale mindset shifts interdisciplinary
education circular design Supply chains
and business models and infrastructure
these are all sites for design to act
the while stem has evolved to include a
for Arts a systems approach to
Innovation is incomplete without a
distinct B for design as Paula Antonelli
and others have long advocated
so given the ecological emergency facing
this planet Earth who then gets to
redesign humankind's relationship with
the living world and the technologies
that mediate it
in 2020 the world economic Forum
convened the global future Council of on
synthetic biology reflecting on the
unrealized Promises of the field and
articulating how the advancement of
synthetic biology can benefit both
people and the planet
four important values to bring this
potential into being emerged from the
council's work Equity humility
sustainability and solidarity
The Forum invited Faber Futures to
engage with the nuance and specific
specificity of what these and other
emergent values mean in practice
so we developed bio stories a project
that embodies how humankind has come
together for millennium to make sense of
the world gathering in circles with
objects for shared storytelling
bio stories is an expansive project
comprising an iterative methodology for
curating hosting and translating
artifact-led multi-stakeholder dialogues
into new narratives and tangible
insights
rather than the usual
emphasis of focusing on the stakeholders
level of understanding of synthetic
biology as a technology instead we
invited stakeholders to share an
artifact representing their own
relationship with the living world
these artifacts prompted discussion spun
out new narratives and modes of
Storytelling that begin to give us a
deeper understanding of what is at stake
as we design the living world
these dialogues inspired the Museum of
symbiosis
and science fiction by writer Claire
Evans that helps us imagine that other
biological features are indeed possible
at the same time Anthropologist Dr
Melissa Psalms dialogue synthesis
analyzes and codifies hours and hours of
transcripts for themes connections and
new directions
from her analysis we learned that
stakeholders revealed an expanded set of
values for us to consider from
discernment to novelty locality and
regenerative by Design
the farmer the engineer the grandmother
the artist and the curator appear
throughout all of the conversations
teaching us how to translate these
values into practice
and significantly tangible insights for
policy makers who wish to enable the
Futures that these stories foreground
include the need to facilitate
Frameworks for problem solving and
curiosity driven research and synthetic
biology developments rooted in
quantitative and qualitative analyzes of
impacts
fire stories offers methods and
practices to democratize participation
generate new narratives and inform
policy for the scale-up of synthetic
biology the full report is freely
available to download from our website
and I encourage you to dig in there's a
lot of content there that's really
inspiring
though in closing I will leave you what
with a final provocation that if taken
seriously can create the conditions for
genuinely Equitable technologies that we
might Upstream another D for democracy
in our approach to science and
innovation
thank you
thank you that was great and now we'll
bring you back on stage uh and Sarah
will you come with me can we see natsai
over there she cannot see us but we want
to see her face she's gonna come back up
here she is we can see you well oh right
now that was a really really great
presentation and it's funny because
we've been talking about grandmothers I
like that you had also the grandmother
in your list and that Amy before talked
about it and I remember seeing an
exhibition in Seoul several years ago at
the Museum it was a media arts festival
called ghosts shamans and grandmothers
so clearly the wisdom of the future
resides with them so this was a a
wonderful conversation and many of the
questions that I received from the
audience are about the uh the apparent
contrast and opposition between the
selfishness of of individuals and the
need instead to have this kind of
generosity altruism and and sense of the
future that is necessary for the mindset
shift that you boast that you both
talked about so let's talk about that do
you see really
um an opposition I'm gonna start with
Sarah because one of the questions was a
specialist about Singapore do you see an
opposition between individual citizens
mindsets and the need instead to act
together
I'm so glad someone asked this question
so I think fundamentally
this is one of the key stories that
needs to be debunked because if you look
back and talk to anthropologists and
archaeologists there's not actually any
evidence any more evidence that we are
fundamentally selfish as people or that
we are unable to cooperate or work
together towards common goals and I
think this is a relatively recent
conception which I know is very much
part of the founding narrative you know
we can think of the founding father you
know the
with great respect but you know saying
things like if you don't work hard
there's always someone else who wants to
eat your lunch and that you know in in
50 over years that can inculcate this
idea
of innate
um competitiveness but I actually
don't think if you look at how things
play out on the ground that you can
necessarily see
evidence of this I mean if you look at
all the mutual Aid organizations
that arose in you know from New York to
Singapore
I don't actually see evidence of this
individual selfishness per se I just
think it's a story that we've
collectively absorbed and sometimes live
into but looking at alternative
alternative stories from by listening to
the grandmothers you know our Collective
grandmothers
um
can help us understand that that's not
necessarily even true
thank you and you know not say similarly
we're talking we're becoming well we've
been very human all day long but it's
getting more and more into that as the
day proceeds and that's how I when I met
you several years ago biodesign was uh
populated by amazing Pioneers but at the
very beginning you too you all had to
really deal with the science and the
design and you didn't have much time to
connect with the rest of the world and
to talk about equity and democracy about
everything that you're talking about
today so there's a maturity to the
discipline that I'm so glad to see was
that difficult did you have to bring
others into the game did you have to
talk to policy makers how did it how did
it happen
I I think you're right Paula that the
kinds of conversations that we're
starting to have now
um within the field
um are shifting towards
um I I think I think when we we first
started um in this field people were
more concerned with how to raise Capital
to
um actually invest in the r d that's
required for some of these Technologies
and now we're moving into a space where
we're talking about how to scale up
those Innovations and once you start to
consider scale up you're really forced
to shift your mindset away from the work
that's happening in the lab to how that
work is going to live in the real world
um because scale up in involves needing
to think about the infrastructures for
that the locality for that the the
supply chains
um the human beings and obviously the
the real measurable environmental impact
of these of these Technologies so I do
think that we are starting to understand
that these Technologies are not
um and so
the the good news is that um actually
within the field of synthetic biology a
lot of researchers have been thinking
long and hard about some of these
um issues primarily the ethical issues
for a really long time now
um and I would say that uh part of that
is is the fact that genetic engineering
um has a bad rep
um because of the actual practices of
businesses
um that that sort of precede this
particular moment in technology
technological um Innovation so a lot of
work has existed
um you know there's a fluency A literacy
in what these issues are so that by the
time we are now here
um thinking practically about what scale
up looks like
across the value chain from startups to
academics
um the conversation is much more evolved
as to how to make it a transformative
technology
policy is being you know written right
now that actually holds a lot of these
value drivers from the start and I think
we've also learned from the digital
Revolution that if you try to do it
after the fact you're not going to make
so much progress so so I'm I'm
optimistic from that perspective that
there is a maturity and a a sense of
reading the room about how we should
implement the Technologies but it is
still very difficult
or you've talked about this with other
panelists today to square that
um with the realities of our economic
Paradigm where
um still people want to understand what
the bottom line is for this there's
still much work to be done I think
reading the room indeed and I I want to
thank you Sarah for bringing us back to
reality and talking about Pakistan and
what's going on there because truly
um this reading the room and everything
that we're discussing also comes from
the fact that the uh the crisis Global
local and at all levels that we're
seeing today are interconnected so it's
about once again system thinking and
system acting Sarah you had a slip at
some point you said degenerative instead
of saying regenerative yes and I I liked
it because I wanted to ask you you both
spoke about extraction and you know this
idea of uh of fighting extraction and
architecture and design fighting
exploitation is something that is very
much discussed so what do you see as
degenerative design can you describe the
opposite of what you're advocating
I know that it's a it's kind of a weird
question but we're all talking in
positives today so yeah sometimes we
forget instead what we're fighting
against I'm so I'm so glad you raised
that Paula thank you I think one of the
major challenges of the sustainability
Paradigm that so much of us are still
working inside is that we kind of think
if we get to the point of neutrality
that's all right but what that leaves
behind is the idea is is that
that is
turning a blind eye to the fact that so
much harm has already occurred
to get us where we are so I think I I
would basically say that anything that
doesn't undo past harms is in itself
okay degenerative interesting so we have
a lot to pay back absolutely and
regenerative design is intrinsically
proactive and not reactive but there's
still some work to do before absolutely
right another question that is
interesting for natsai what are the
economic viable opportunities for
regenerative design and biotechnology
so how is there still economic viability
or you're still kind of like Investing
For future returns that are also
Financial
I I think that's um a really difficult
question to to answer because of how
wide the application space is
um a lot of people are primarily focused
right now on scaling their Technologies
to make the underlying technology itself
um viable
um the the expanded opportunities
um there are are tied to what it means
to actually Implement at scale
um in in the real world
um and I think that when we start to
connect with this this value that came
up in BIO stories of um what are the
local implication of these Technologies
do we want to centralize or do we want
to decentralize then you can start to
see how this other value that's been
created
um as you uh start to map out your your
business plan and strategy about where
you're going to be operational from and
I think for me what's really exciting is
if decisions are made about a
distributed approach to biotechnology
um that places demands actually on the
living organism in terms of
um its productive capacity and the kinds
of feedstocks for example all of these
organisms feed on sugar and and that is
one of the the tricky components of this
um but if we understand that we can
actually design an organism to
um to consume uh a specific feedstock
that has a low environmental impact then
we can we can we have a lot of
flexibility to start to add value to
places by deciding to set up shop
um there but I think that um the the
this is a very much a long-term Endeavor
and the opportunity we have right now is
to put the kinds of systems in place to
allow those opportunities to to to
emerge what I worry about is that we
actually foreclose the possibility of
other kinds of models in how we build
out these um biotechnologies if we
primarily focus on replacing ingredients
in our present system we have to see it
from a much wider perspective makes
sense did you have a chance to listen to
Stephen cares before I don't know if you
were if you were online yes
I could be the end of it I did yeah so
you you will see everything in the
recording
um one last question question for Sarah
very very down to earth and
understandable what are some of the key
strategies for a regenerative design
approach you should buy the book but
yeah yeah wow
unlike and Aaron and Emmy I didn't give
the breakdown of our Point by points but
gotta buy the book
well I think I mean the beauty of how
you've curated this Symposium Paula is
that we've actually heard a number of
them already from the previous speakers
I think if you think about the projects
that Munson and normal
um are initiating or the research
they're they're initiating with their
students this idea of taking
responsibility within a given place and
for a building's own needs and then
maybe moving beyond that to making a
positive contribution so I'd say a sort
of place based literacy that takes
responsibility
um
for the long term I'd say is the key
place to start and
ground in place and uh the uh the
responsibility of the individual in all
this when we're talking about agency you
know the Symposium is called Agency for
the future
so the individual as the designer I
certainly what I love is almost everyone
who identifies as a designer that I've
heard from today is in no way shrinking
from their responsibility right everyone
is looking you know we've we've heard
from everyone today about how they are
looking to expand their own agency and
nazar's talking about you know moving to
influence the system right not just in
not just switching out ingredients not
just ending up with more toxic sludge
bricks right and sludge bricks I love
them from mailing so again I think I'm
so pleased that you chose that for the
name of this topic that we we all have
the capacity to expand yes it's also
where's Mark yeah everyone but thank you
very much natsai thank you Sarah I natai
uh yeah I hope that we will see each
other soon and uh we we all thank you
very much and you'll get the recording
of the whole Symposium soon so you'll be
able to enjoy some quite a few Kindred
Spirits I can tell you so thank you ciao
thank you thank you so much
[Applause]